all erode in David is there a particular
word or phrase that immediately makes
you think someone is not intelligent
listen intelligence and ignorant sore
sometimes two different things
intelligence to me is more the ability
to think and reason and learn
whereas ignorant is just the lack of
knowledge about certain facts or ideas
or concepts and I think that those are
two different things one thing that I
always find to be absolutely idiotic is
when someone starts talking about their
own IQ particularly as a way to defend a
point in an argument which is just
completely fallacious right the fact
that you claim to have an IQ of 110 or
130 or 150 or whatever because you're
trying to defend an assertion that you
made that to me signals a lack of
reasoning skills because you should
anybody who's truly well-versed in
rhetoric and understands the scientific
method and understands sort of debate
and argument and and epistemology would
know that stating your IQ is is not
evidence that any particular factor
assertion is or isn't true and you know
generally speaking the smartest people I
know they're number one they don't even
know what their IQ is because it's never
occurred to them to go and get tested
and number two if they if they know what
their IQ is they recognize that it's not
really something to talk about
particularly in social situations or in
defense of an assertion that you're
making right the late great Stephen
Hawking who had an IQ of around 160 then
he said that people who brag about their
IQ are idiots and I tend to agree with
that I think the other signal to me of
someone's ignorant and again it's not
necessarily lack of intelligence I think
lack of intelligence is more difficult
to assess it's us out but ignorant can
be more obvious
is when in front of people you've just
met you start saying pejorative things
about racial groups or religious groups
or whatever especially like I said when
you don't know your audience right that
seems to me to be a very ignorant thing
to do there are smart people who are
racist there are smart people who are
xenophobic there are smart people who
are homophobic whatever else the case
may be but there's a certain level of
ignorant that I associate with starting
to say things like that in groups you've
groups of people you've just met
particularly in business situations
where there could be a job or contracts
riding on that's on that sort of stuff
and some people will say David there
they might not be ignorant they might
just be so steadfast in those beliefs
that they don't they want to make clear
what they are to get people who disagree
with them out of their that's the rare
exception I find it extremely ignorant
when people do that and it makes me
question their judgment more broadly
what about like errors in grammar or you
know just miss stating an expression
like someone who says I could care less
well yeah I mean I couldn't care less I
associate that as much I don't think
that that's lack of intelligence I think
that that's just lack of knowledge of
certain phrases I - well as opposed to I
might as or yeah I should of instead of
should have but ya think that means that
maybe you're not so well read and we
tend to have a correlation between you
know someone's reading ability you
actually read and intelligence well yeah
I mean I guess you have to then it gets
more complicated because you've got to
account for words that this person learn
English as a second language right or
whatever when someone says as an
Aquarian right relating to like for
example I was born in February so I'm an
Aquarius is my astrological sign if I'm
ever having what I consider to be a
serious conversation with someone and
they bring in what their position is or
an analysis of my position based on my
astrological sign I don't know whether I
put that in the unintelligent or
ignorant category but that will torpedo
my personal opinion of the person like
that because that's like identity Pollux
to identity politics right it's a yes
yes sense the astrological signs I like
that it's identity politics meets
pseudoscience or something like that
yeah that that's definitely a red flag
for me and also the the other one that I
think is probably on my list is any time
anyone out and out dismisses some sort
of key issue of culture as irrelevant
it's not about their intelligence but my
view of their ignorance of their whether
they are ignorant is certainly affected
so if I'm talking to someone and they
seem generally well adjusted about sort
of what's going on like it's not someone
who doesn't pay attention to any news
it's someone who clearly is aware of
things that are going on in the world
and you
up some issue like oh you know do you
know what's going on right now with the
the tax bill or something like that and
they don't say I'm not paying attention
to it they say I just don't think it
mattered I just don't think what taxes
are at all makes any difference to
anyone I don't think we should worry
about it it's just not an important
issue it's not that they're not unaware
of politics yeah that's one thing that
makes me wonder what else they sort of
misunderstand about the factors that
influence our day-to-day lives and our
sort of socio-cultural status quo just
sounds like a appeal to futility to
which is the logical fallacy yeah that
yeah that that that certainly could be
said as well
today's episode is made possible in part
by zipper ZPE our banks and other
financial institutions are pretty
conservative when it comes to approving
loans and the major problem with this is
not that they're being cautious but that
immigrants and students and other
disadvantaged groups often don't have
the requisite credit or income to be
approved Zippers goal is to use smart
contract technology and their new
cryptocurrency to provide a
revolutionary method of funding
transactions between borrowers and
lenders worldwide which would allow
people with no or little credit to
borrow currency through alternative
forms of verifying creditworthiness on
Zippers blockchain Zippers initial coin
offering for their new cryptocurrency
starts April 16th if you're watching on
YouTube look in the description for a
link to their website and links to
information about their airdrop and
bounty programs this is not financial
advice and everybody should do their own
research